[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
b
pour l'ès à prendre
la seconde arrive en live en ait que
deux en lice avait il seulement besoin
de le présenter
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'un dispose labs ont compensé que et
humide les tories mais en mode hôtesse
de l'air john lennon le sud est
elles sont géniales salon rose elles
sont extraordinaires
assad
[Musique]
regardez le petit cadeau que caro me
transmet mais je kiffe de ouf
mais tu parles des grandes oreilles
non mais jacques ifs
bon enfin bon vous l'aurez compris
aujourd'hui on est en jour off mais pour
le jour férié bon bah voilà ça tombe
bien il ya de la tempête d'euros
donc ce matin on a fait un hammam à
gloucester nous et puis maintenant je
repars elle va découvrir ta fille est la
fille de la mère ou la france manar
coucou toi
bon ben dilla déjà bondi à refuser une
soirée merveilleuse parce que demain
matin je dois me réveiller très tôt
parce qu'il ya un invité mystère
alors du coup à fond du court moi je me
sépare solidarité voilà aller en voiture
si mon coup je montre en tort ouais je
suis tombé payer l'addition mais juste
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
bon celui-là quelqu'un qu'on connaît
très bien
comment ça va
écoute ça va on est content de faire la
coupe du monde féminine sur canal et
puis bah bah du coup évidemment j'ai
plutôt numéro un seul tout le monde non
plus donc tu seras gentil de me renvoyer
un sms je puisses te crier régulièrement
en amour une mon admiration vous
embrasse tous
[Musique]